Now there is a rule.
the 6895
99.7 rule
Yeah, I'll show you a picture of it from Wikipedia.
and it says this
okay.
If you have a normal distribution.
if
the experiment that you're looking at or the sample space
containing the experiment.
Is within one standard deviation of the mean.
This is assuming that the experiments have
a normal distribution to begin with.
Okay, if they have a normal distribution if they're
within one standard deviation away from the mean there's a
68%
probability that there was experiments will take place.
two standard deviations away
from the mean 95%
probability that they will
You know occur.
and of course if we go three standard deviations away
from the mean
99.7
% probability that they will take place.
If you go past three standard deviation, that's Overkill now I'm talking
about this because when we get into the
topic of estimation
Which leads us to?
Ultimately two topics, we will finish our series with
two topics hypothesis, testing and
regression analysis.
Everything we are learning.
Is going to lead it's going to lead to that point where we
will look at one.
Comprehensive statistical study what we do one hypothesis test.
And a regression analysis with r and visualization
will have different we will
have different graphs to look at like histograms Scatter
Plots with fitting ball plots,
all that good stuff. Okay, and knowing this information knowing
this rule about the normal distribution is is very
Okay, and that's what this text is talking about
here.
as you go
as you take the problem the CDF.
of standard deviations and you step away from the mean the probability
will increase okay because you you are
Well, I mean it's in the name you're accumulating more probability.
across the experiments
This is just rephrasing what we
talked about earlier. Now the results of this example
are often reporting percentage for of course, you
can't do that.
the number of probabilities between of course
you are one, but if you want percentage, you can
just multiply it and you can
use percentage